frisky britches is changing the way
women shop for underwear no more
emergency runs to the store on laundry
days or digging through piles of
underwear to find something that you
like instead frisky britches sent to
brand-name panties straight to your door
each month as a woman who considers
herself a full time scumbag I can say
that this is an actually wonderful
company and a great service and you will
thank me later go to frisky britches
they have your back when it comes to
feeling your best starting from the
moment you put on your britches go to
shop
frisky britches com2 get started and get
20% off your first month using the code
grace welcome to another episode of not
to your deep with me grace and how big
the first today we have an amazing
comedian actor writer and a punk band
extraordinaire performer
johnross Maui is here with us you know
him from speechless you know him from
the Big Bang Theory and you're about to
know a little bit more about his
old-school roots in the punk band egg
head he's ready heard this episode of
not too deep with John Ross Maui it's
always fascinating for me to go on like
the social media platforms of like the
people that exist in you know
traditional media and see like how they
operate there because I myself have been
doing it for so long and I still like my
blood boils when I go online I get like
a visceral reaction and like a weird
kind of chaos in my brain of like how do
I exist on social media in what way
should I use this said platform for
something yeah that that whole idea of
what we are platforming and what ideas
were putting forward and you know are
our own and others is uh daunting very
daunting yeah and so I wonder like it
must be kind of freeing to be able to
act because then you get to like just
kind of exist creatively without
consequence and then to like do
something on Twitter or on Instagram or
whatever it might be
feels heavier than that well I wouldn't
say I wouldn't share without consequence
I mean I am I'm occasionally personally
called out for you know content of of
the things I'm working on and and there
is always that deflection of like yeah
well you want to actually talk to the
writers I'm a I'm an independent
contractor it's not my I just put up the
drywall don't look at me and I'm not
designing the house so there is a
certain degree of responsibility that I
think previous generations of actors
never knew from you know something
people were you know tweeting Sean
Connery and the sixties and being like
your character is sexist so you know
there'll be something you know will
especially honest or like like
speechless we're we're we're tackling
something that is not dealt with in
television in general but specifically
not in comedy yeah we're gonna we're
gonna misstep now and again we're gonna
use the wrong word or something sure but
I think it's you learn as you go and
also I think it's a great my mom just
recently retired but she work with
special needs kids like for her an
entire like eunuch yeah she was a
teacher's assistant in a class with
special-needs kids and so when I watch
speechless I was very like excited by
the idea of not making it feel precious
like no making it feel normal making it
feel real making it feel like the way we
all exists in the world and I thought
that must have been a cool project for
you to sign on to when you first heard
about it but like cool let this is the
first entry into dialogue that is
different than the way we've been
talking about like kids with you know
special needs before it was interesting
because in like four four pages into the
pilot there's a moment where where the
the middle child tells his older brother
JJ who uses a wheelchair calls him a
bully because JJ is being a dick and it
was it was it's a throwaway line he just
looks down at him bully Wow that's
that's a whole new paradigm isn't it
that's that's that's that's brand new
we've not seen that before and it made
me really really want the job
it yeah I think the idea is just what
you said to to to talk about it but keep
it from getting too precious definitely
keep it from getting too sentimental
yeah and and at the same time you know
be you know honest and respectful but
but recognize that you know he's a
teenager before he's anything else oh
yeah he's a human being at the end of
the day like his brain and his needs and
wants operate the same way that we all
need and want things which i think is so
cool about that show but also as a dad
you have two kids yeah how old they are
11 and 8 god bless ya yes oh they're
preteens they are preteens of oh god man
my 11 year old is in a rush to get there
she is she was like literally rushing us
already and she's rushing tri-delt
I know UCLA has like I knew they know
she's just in terms of like you know the
odd door slam yeah and the occasional no
one is listening to me stuff that's
that's happening already and we are the
fun soundtrack to live by everyday
they're great kids they really are great
kids and I adore them but yeah they they
present and they're completely they're
crazy in two different directions too so
it's not like go both of our kids have
the same issue they're just like they're
they're often their own little camps
being crazy in their own respective ways
and it's a it's about patience yeah yeah
you could deal with just one Avenue do
they think you're cool or lame for being
an actor you know the I think that's one
of the things they think is cool there
are a million things about me that they
find lame but the the acting thing I
think they're pretty psyched about are
they and I think it gives them cool
credit by default it might give them
cool credit by default I think they what
the great thing about speech loss is
that I can as occasionally
gee as it is I can still watch it with
my kids yeah you're in they do I mean
not everything but yeah they they watch
they watch speechless it is
honest-to-goodness it's like they're
really psyched when there's a new
episode which is a lovely feeling you
know have they seen the episode of House
of Lies where I suck on Kristen Bell's
toes no they have not what they would
gain from that I call I call Gillian
Jacobs a [ __ ] [ __ ] on Netflix is love
none of their business they don't need
that I mean yeah my dad has said things
not filmed that I don't need to know
about precisely um so but yeah I think
for the moment they they think it's it's
it's pretty interesting and they are
they enjoy it yeah I think it's good
yeah that's really good are they friends
are they had like with each other yeah
oh the the short answer is yes as of
this morning around 7:40 now no asterisk
oh my god it really is I think in the
larger I mean there's plenty of times
when when my older girl questions why we
had a younger boy it's a personal attack
that you and your wife did to her uh-huh
yeah no she's very personally she seems
to think it was rather vindictive and
that's odd but it's it's mostly yeah
they get along and when they don't see
my wife and I are both only children so
children raising children
yeah so when I raise so when we see
these two kids fighting or just like go
away from each other I guess I don't
know what to tell you no I mean that's
when I talked to Maya about it like the
fact that she raises young boys like it
blows my mind that I'm like how are you
so of sound mind well also your brain
has to be so intense with like how do we
fix this they are both upset and we
don't know what to do other than
animals separate so your mom's got to
you've got two younger brothers I have
an older brother and a younger brother
okay yes I'm the middle child yeah but
it's uh ya know it's intense I and I
don't know how you deal with it while
being in the creative universe at the
same well you can't really do both you
gotta just be home and completely
focused on that once in a great while
I'll get a call from like a sitter
Shane like Walter is doing blank can you
deal with Walter and I'll put him on the
phone once great like we're gonna have
to hold the roll yeah tiny match but
they but yeah I think by and large it my
thing is I think they're gonna really
appreciate having each other as they get
older
oh yeah my younger brother is two years
younger two and a half years younger
than me and yeah we were at odds growing
up and then as adults we become like
really really close friends so that's
good to hear and hope that was the long
game you know that's what we were aiming
for is something like yeah Jill did
according yeah they're about 27 months
apart and um and you know he's a big
dumb boy and he crashes in there and she
is number of levels he really is a sweet
kid but just Hulk smash and he so he's a
lot and and but then again she's a lot
and she once mom pick your battles man
no he just fired it on the couch we
don't have to make this World War three
but if it's a fabric couch it absorbs
the smell and it will never go away so
that's worth fighting for
poster okay you grew up in New York City
I did born and raised
yeah born in Queens photographer
Manhattan born in Queens and then you
went to Ithaca College I did which is
outside of New York to the tune of about
five hours but yeah yes I went to Ramapo
College which is in northern New Jersey
which is close to Ithaca and I remember
people transferred from my college to go
to Ithaca because that was the step up
you know how I found ethica
it was my senior year girlfriend's
safety school that's how I so so much
for Ramapo dan which would have made
Ramapo my safety school then if we're
following this so you went to Ithaca
because it was your high school
girlfriends no it's just how I just
discovered eyes like with Sam what's it
the guns you know it's this little
school in central New York what the
thing is that if the cut itself is
awesome the town itself is actually it's
beautiful I've never been it's really
really gorgeous really sorry that's a
that's a big thing is gorgeous it's an
off to use pile is a six mile Gorge that
cuts through them or the t-shirt I never
did good but it is really it is it is a
photogenic butyl ottoman Ithaca it's
just like you can't even believe you're
near this level of natural beauty
especially if you came if you grew up in
Manhattan it's a really progressive town
for a small town interesting it it had a
had a socialist mayor for all four years
that I was there that ran who ran
unopposed Nichols and I don't mean like
his name was Ben Nichols and Nichols and
I know I don't mean like he tap-danced
on the side because that sounds like a
Ben Nichols thing no he just he really
just tried to you know tax tax the
wealthy and and and keep businesses
small in downtown Ithaca and he was a
legitimate like ran on the socialist
ticket I'm not like using it like oh you
know what the Democrats are they're all
socialists I mean the guy's straight up
ran as a socialist and won twice and he
and so the town's got this it's a real
college town I'm you've got ethic
ecology you've got Cornell right across
town right cuz it was the thing wasn't
there like a field party that happened
between those two schools once a year
that's the mythology that I heard about
ethica and Cornell is that there was
some like big field in between these two
colleges and that everyone would party
in the field once a year
that might have been just like a selling
point for kids to go from Ramapo to
Ithaca I don't know when not when I was
there we hardly ever saw the Cornell
students off campus
okay we're really working very hard in
these the students were not we're going
downtown to see Blues Traveler myself
Class of 93 what's up yeah you guys are
art students you gotta take in the
culture so it was this so yeah it's this
beautiful town and I guess I went
because of the of the towns I went into
it was far enough away that I wouldn't
be tempted just to like go back to New
York every weekend I wanted to really
push myself a little bit like something
that I think is very hard or I assume is
very hard are people that live in New
York you know to get out of the city and
in engage in nature trees greenery a
slower pace of life people that are
slightly more considerate than others it
was a massive adjustment and I remember
going up there one down again this is
1989 but I remember calling trying to
call my mom at one point and being told
on the phone that all the outgoing
circuits in the town were busy thing
that happens that's not but it was you
know I still have my issues with you
know being a tightly wound New Yorker
but so if it hadn't been for four years
in Ithaca I think I'd be a disaster I
really I think it slowed media just a
breath of fresh air just like a
patient's deceleration and a
readjustment of priorities and what and
it was really crucial for me I think
also you get to see people that exist
outside of New York because New York I
feel like I lived there for a few years
that's where I met Jack in New York and
it we both grew up in Jersey and so it's
the pace of life and the the fighting
for space constantly for space yeah but
like the subconscious fighting for space
oh no it's a constant struggle yeah yeah
and then when you leave it then you're
like what is breathing what is space
mean
and like now you living in Los Angeles
now for so long like that must be also
an adjustment it has been yeah and I
really like it yeah you do like la a lot
yeah it took me a second I did not like
it at first because I was so accustomed
to the pace of New York that when I got
out here I didn't trust people that
actually wanted to know what was wrong
just like what do you want from me
what do you want what do you need but no
that's fascinating okay they're just
legitimately checking in when you let
them help you I trust no one I hear that
we don't carry all my bags with me at
all times everywhere I don't leave
anything in my car here's what I miss I
miss autumn in autumn in New York is
pretty and this season so to speak and
no I don't miss Susan so you miss me you
heard me wrong I missed I did four years
in it's like a [ __ ] winter forever I
missed the other two weeks where the
leaves look nice and everyone's okay
with not picking up snow sign me up
yeah lovely yeah and then when the snow
is black by mid-february I miss that you
missed getting that in your socks do you
really you're nostalgic for that Woody
Allen I will not romanticize that place
I mean I'm glad I'm from there I'm I did
thirty years of my life there and and
that was great
but yeah I like it out here kind of wish
we weren't on fire quite as often as we
are the environs but I like it yeah we
sub smoke for fire so it works out okay
the we're gonna take a break in a second
but before we do I wanted to ask you
about cuz you from what I've heard and
maybe you talked about this a million
times over and you don't have to if you
don't want to just that you worked at an
office job for a long time yeah so what
were the office jobs that you worked at
before you got into like the groove of
acting before you got into like this is
not right before a commercial break
question I mean I I worked in I I was
temping but I was a lot of these jobs
who were tempted parameters or they were
always like looking for you listening we
got some openings here if you want to
check this out so I worked in publishing
and advertising and pharmaceuticals and
engineering and reinsurance and
insurance they're two different things
consulting accounting
television Loosli television production
like i worked for the president program
a WPIX but i did I did a full-time like
actual on the clock with benefits at a
very large consulting firm what does
that mean what is consulting meme again
man we are you're trying to go into a
break here I will say this a lot of its
horseshit consulting and but it
basically is they are a a it's a
partnership that goes to corporations
and help and quote-unquote helps their
businesses run more smoothly but nine
times out of ten that means they
restructure their Human Resources which
means they do mass layoffs got it yeah
so did were any of those jobs something
that you wanted upward mobility and
there were a couple where I thought
about it really and I was I was at the
consulting firm long enough to get a
raise sounds like you bounced around a
bit yeah yeah yeah you you tasted all
the flavors of the rainbow in the world
my parents worked in offices and it just
it kind of felt like I had a deep-seated
need to be an actor since when I was a
little kid but it looked just so
unstable right especially growing up in
New York where you see you don't just
see the successful actors you see the
ones who are struggling and you see you
know that on my block there are people
who are you know scraping by sure who
are on Broadway one year and our waiting
tables the next yeah and I think I
looked to office work as a source of
like well this is what grown-up
stability stability yeah and this is
what it means to be an adult yeah and it
just eventually broke me like a twig and
I was like I have to at least least try
acting you can't say it eventually broke
you like a twig when you have a resume
of 12,000 different jobs myself back
together it seems like you kept putting
the twig back into a branch I really did
no you're not wrong I kept going well
maybe this is the one maybe this is the
job that I will like and gosh these are
pretty offices and look at this view and
you know you do you tell yourself all a
number of things and I'm not knocking
people who work in an office because I
think it's it's you know it's there the
engine of the economy I just was bad at
it yeah yeah same I worked in office for
three months and I just and then I went
back to
waiting tables cuz I couldn't deal with
fluorescent lighting I couldn't deal
with just like I got upset by like the
rules of the hours that I had to be
there when I wasn't doing anything that
was actually helping the company and the
looking busy part is really hard which
is acting in a way yes they're all named
Joe no all everyone in office named Jim
stress says no that's science if you
guys are applying for jobs at any point
you better get ready what was quickly
the shortest job that you had temping if
you remember was there any that you were
literally revolving door in and out I
got fired from a pharmaceutical company
just for I just I don't even remember
where I got fired I was not I was I
guess I was slacking off or or whatever
there wasn't a it wasn't any like
massive know like circumstance that
happened no I just I was bumping heads
with my supervisor and like my whole
deal was I was supposed to set up a
meeting with all these executives and
none of the executives knew who I was so
none of them returned my call
so I was just in this cycle of like I
will set up the meeting when these
people called me back and they're not
calling me back
and so became this whole this whole
cycle of thing but I remember
specifically at that time the
pharmaceutical company was had
introduced a drug onto the market a
heart medication for older people who
had angina and they were being
investigated by the Justice Department
because some people had died from from
not from screen up the dosage from
taking two pills instead of one okay and
if two is an overdose and one is the
proper dosage that's an unstable drug
but but so but they gave us this press
release where they were like here you
know if you are contacted by any members
of the media here are the talking points
and one of the talking points was an it
was you were allowed to say that yes one
of the side effects of the drug if
improperly used huh was total mortality
total mortality not half mortality total
more town 1/4 mortality total Humberts
and 100%
Wow
oh and it was that kind of corporate
Newspeak that just eventually drove me
out of my mind
it was Edgar Allan Poe writing these PR
God would that it were Poe oh wow
one of the side effects is Nevermore I
mean but that's giving you the
experience and the tools and the tool
chest of things that you can pull from
and it does like you know sometimes it's
really important to know what you don't
want to do of I a thousand percent
subscribe to that philosophy and I'm
also like every once in a while I'll
meet an actor who's my age my age is
like you know total mortality or total
mortality I'm hovering around 60 percent
right now but I'll meet an actor my age
who has to have wardrobe tie his tie for
him and like you've never worked in an
office never worked in an office rank
amateur you have never worked in an
office in fact you've never even waited
tables at some place nice it's it's like
my one little trigger it really adds a
little bit of snobbery that comes
through where I'm like simple foreign
hand you're in your 40s you should know
this I think they should sub home ik for
waiting tables at the Chili's in every
high school just so you can learn about
lately MFA program no high school okay
we're gonna take a quick break and when
we get back we have more questions about
you know just total mortality here on
not your teeth
[Music]
too deep they subs up not too deep
it's brought to you by a body boss
squeezing in time for your family work
and hitting the gym feels impossible so
something's got to give and it's
probably the gym but body boss can help
unlock your dream body with the great 12
week body boss workout program do it at
home in just 24 minutes a day three days
a week that's less than 90 minutes a
week with no equipment and no
subscription thanks to the hashtag Boss
effect or excess post-exercise oxygen
consumption you burn fat longer after
your workout plus with caring pro
coaches and a free Facebook group of
supportive kick-ass women you are never
alone so try body boss with the special
offer just for you listeners get 25% off
the fitness guide at body boss calm /
grace order now and get free shipping
and a money-back guarantee this is the
best deal ever get body boss for 25
percent off at body boss calm / grace 12
weeks from now you'll think yourself
starting now that's body boss calm /
grace the burst sonic toothbrush is the
best oral care you'll ever buy the burst
sonic toothbrush has built-in two minute
timer and is designed to make teeth
whiter and brighter in just days burst
is best known for its charcoal infused
super soft bristles the charcoal removes
surface stains and is antimicrobial
which helps keep the bristles hygienic
for the lifetime of the brush head it's
proven to remove plaque and stains
without damaging the enamel of your gums
burst has the most powerful motor on the
market and the longest battery life with
up to four weeks use on just 1 hours
charge it's fantastic they sent me one
of these toothbrushes and I absolutely
love it the built-in timer is an
excellent little like accessory it keeps
you really in the know of how slowly or
quickly you're brushing your teeth so I
highly recommend go to burst oral
CARICOM to get your burst sonic
toothbrush today and with the burst
subscription program you'll get a new
replacement head every three months for
just six dollars each and if you use my
code grace Jerry Cee at checkout you'll
get 10% off your order
that's burst oral care calm with code
grace for 10% off don't miss out on the
special offer it's a great gift idea too
just saying go to burst or old care.com
and used code grace okay we're talking a
little bit about improv comedy it's got
comedy
UCB etc I always love to hear because it
just I think you know brings us closer
together about your worst comedy show
experience if there's one that comes to
mind Jesus I'm blessed that I have
several I remember we would do we had a
show around the turn of the century
uh-huh here at me y2k do you survive the
riots and looting stop we had a show
from like 99 to fall 99 to fall 2001
called feature feature yeah it was
improvised movies you see was a double
feature of improvised me improvised
movie it's full movie full movies you
know we fade in on and we were off that
we would get a we get a song lyric for
the suggestion and that would give a
sort of an image or whatever and we were
we would do we didn't pick the genre
beforehand we would stumble across stuff
like you know indie like 40s noir we did
a MGM musical we one time did a
blaxploitation film and this was before
smartphones thank God Wow whew yeah the
but it was a it was a it was it it was a
really fun show and it was a
crowd-pleaser who would sell out a free
and I was Saturday nights at 10 o'clock
and yeah it was kind of our thing
anytime we took that show on the road
like we went to add Improv Festival in
Chicago or wherever I just felt like we
we just we were we did not have the home
court advantage
yeah just [ __ ] the bed he just never
Berkeley me I remember specifically
being like I am having a bad show
tonight this is not going well for Jon
and I know it's about the ensemble and
the team but it was still hard to not be
like wow I am NOT this is not going the
way it's an int yeah
and the cast was as my wife Jamie Denbo
it was Rob Corddry and Brian Huskey and
Seth Morrison and all these great people
were we're in the show we'll Burson
scott armstrong dynamo
really really strong people we'd have
we'd have guys like Owen Burke guests
with us sometimes yeah but it was it
would any time we took it off campus
yeah we just really that's hi-de-hi we
asked Thomas Middleditch a little bit
about this too like with him traveling
that anytime you go it's interesting to
see where your sweet spots are in the
country outside of New York yeah just
tons of trim and Ben do that tour and
they go everywhere everywhere but did
you guys have a sweet spot outside of
New York or was New York literally home
court advantage and they did not have a
sweet spot okay I'll grant you we did
not do the extensive touring that
Middleditch and Schwartz do but we got
out enough to know that like yeah it's
uh it was really interesting I don't
know if there is something magical about
a UCB audience I will say this I mean
they show up game yeah show up
interesting ready to experiment and
ready to have a good time they come with
a positive attitude which is bizarre in
New York that people show up with a
positive attitude but there's everything
in one place but it's also it just
fosters community it fosters literally
like we're all here together we're doing
this together this exists for us right
now right here yeah and that's what I
hate I love so much about improv is like
the lack of smartphones the lack of
filming the lack of you know watching it
back like the existence and presence in
the moment yeah but you still perform
you and your wife still perform out here
and occasionally yeah occasionally yeah
again that you heard the thing about the
two kids the two chains we do what we do
a two-person show called super married
[Music]
because we met doing improv in the fall
of 98 uh-huh um taking our level 2 class
with with Amy Poehler as our teacher
never heard of her and uh maybe she'll
and I think she waits tables actually
Armando was her was my level 1 her
mother he founded the Penn yeah yeah I
got I got in its it the one time in my
life I could say I was kinda in on the
ground floor yeah
I'm late to the party on so many things
but I I was cutting on the ground floor
when UCB came to New York yeah that's
incredible so I got like all the big
teachers either as teachers or as
coaches at one point or another that's
amazing so it was so I took with Ian in
both mats and Amy and Wow
Ali I took a sketch writing class with
Ali and it was yeah it was a monologuing
and you guys taking notes occasionally
some good things from Molly's class but
he you and your wife doing improv now do
you guys have ground rules is there a
safe word when it's like this is getting
too real in a scene you're talking about
something we haven't resolved as a
couple it's really funny you asked us
because we don't have a safe word but we
have a convention that we did she sprang
on me one night and now we go back to it
where we will be doing a scene and if it
goes off the rails we will cut to the
car after the show and she'll be driving
she initiated this one time and because
a scene had just gone I don't member how
it had gone off the rails but had gone
off the rails
so we hunkered down and we started in
the scene and she's like what the hell
was that all about and now it's it and
now it's become a it killed and it keeps
killing it and it's a convention we go
back to when we do this show of like
little check-in yeah and what's playing
ourselves and we're improvising the
conversation kind of hashing through
what went right and what didn't go right
and you guys also get to be the voice of
the audience yeah exactly and and but
also ourselves because we're tireless
self critics and you know how about Papa
you don't play my mom and the scene how
about you do that up how about we never
do that again you know and it's it
becomes this sort of act to break yeah
we can introduce in to kind of get our
footing again it's interesting so we
don't have a safe word if we had a safe
where we wouldn't need the car scene got
it well so your wife is a genius and I
would love for you to ask her to be my
podcast know that
very fun it seems like to have a
significant other that you get to play
with and be ridiculous with and then
also raise children with is kind of like
fun date night for us to we'll try to
get you if we can get like a 7:30 slot
of ECB whoa and catch dinner afterwards
whoa because we're cached by 10:00
that's pretty sweet
yeah yeah I mean sleep in yeah okay
here's a question so you recently made
her stage debut with the play laughter
on the 23rd floor yes okay
professional like actual run of a play
debut yeah very impressive Neil Simon
wrote it in 1993 at set in 1953 can you
explain the plot to an 11 year old
you know what TV is Right heard of it so
back when TV was really early on early
on in the days of TV like before mommy
and daddy were born uh-huh
there was actually I'm going down I live
in your old it's like it's about the
early days of television my 11 year old
Kevin saw it it's about the early days
of TV is based on Neil Simon used to
write on a show called your show of
shows which was a hit the way we don't
have hits anymore like if you were
watching TV chances are you were
watching your show of shows way off the
country that had TVs would have been
watching Sid Caesar and your show of
shows and this is loosely based on his
time on the writing staff there and so
we were all playing comedy writers in
the early 1950s with you know the
specter of McCarthyism kind of looming
over everything and these traditional
demands of TV executives to make the
show less smart and more accessible and
it was interesting it's you know it's
it's Neil Simon and it's not even one of
the great Neil Simon's maybe so there's
some corny stuff in it and there's some
jokes that were like they were like dad
jokes oh god I'm really gonna have to
like it was an effort to get these over
the finish line some of these jokes but
but it was interesting as sort of a
timepiece also it must be interesting to
do stage versus doing something like Big
Bang Theory doing you know just agent
Bang Theory I think that's an easy
transition stage and speechless or a
bigger jump but Big Bang Theory you got
an audience yeah you'll play it's a play
a week yeah and you rehearse for a week
and then you put it up in front of an
audience who are predisposed to dig you
no question she's Big Bang Theory but
you know you you have to learn how to
surf laughs and how to you know not cut
other people off and have that choice so
I think it did equip me a belief or
doing a neo Simon play sure but yeah
it's it's what's interesting versus it
really is just the physics of it for TV
you're framed like this you can act
accordingly for a play there's people
who are you know 300 feet away from you
right and you have to act so that they
can read your emotion right so you're
trying to be real but you're also trying
to be demonstrative at the same time
yeah and like where is the fine line
between all of that which was really fun
was really fun really really fun to like
play with it like oh and we had a month
for her so we had like a professional
theater schedule so we had a five days a
week rehearsal and it's one of those
plays where once everyone's out on stage
they just stay there you know there's
not a lot of exits and entrances we're
just all out there yeah so you would
have to pages three pages where you
wouldn't speak which is another great
exercise in like being a human being
existing existing without taking focus
yeah I I yeah being the best extra of
all time basically it was neat too is
that the the people I was working with
we had this cast of theatre vets some of
whom had done Broadway yeah and it was I
just got so much watching them listen to
other people and just the the the hard
work that went into it was really a
blast but well it was fun fun but that's
what you know that it's hard work is
that it looks effortless it looks easy
it looks normal it looks like you
haven't really done much rehearsal for
it not knowing that you have put all
these hours and you have put all this
time and mental energy into all of this
to make it look normal yeah I think by
the time we got it up it was it was a
really tightly wound machine and would
you do it again would you do more like
stage stuff oh I'd love to
really oh god I'd love is there a
passion project you haven't done yet
that you really want to get into oh God
you know there's classic plays I'd like
to love you know I'm aging into George
from Who's Afraid of Virginia Woolf you
know I didn't play that it's a
three-and-a-half-hour play but I'd love
to do that thank you very cool yeah
there's all sorts of you know I'd love
to do Richard the third I slouch anyway
let's do this yeah I yeah I had a great
time doing theater and I loved that I
loved having a shitty nut
having a shitty show and knowing that
tomorrow night another chance yeah oh
yeah cuz it lives and dies looking like
24-hour it really does I loved it really
is true what they say every audience is
different yeah did you have any standout
audiences that just like they didn't
know what they were buying tickets for
and they showed up and this is like not
for them oh yeah we had like some some
it was interesting because because it is
a 30 year old play that is said 60 years
ago yeah it is it was the only time in
my career and I've said this before but
it is worth repeating it's the only time
in my career I've ever looked out at the
audience been like ah they're really old
we got this we got this guy's they are
ours to lose this is us cuz you know how
like you'd like if you were doing a UCB
show you peacock like that's an older
crowd tonight guys let's let's watch it
out there let's tread lightly but if I'm
going out there with a joke about how
you know Lana Turner's super hot or you
know some reference to General MacArthur
I want an older audience they're in your
pocket really are and it was so there
were some audiences that were just low
that remembered this [ __ ] you know that
hey yes you were joking
there's this guy chasing gray --sole who
played the lead and the the the Neil
Simon proxy basically who narrates the
play and he has a few moments where he
has to talk about Senator McCarthy and
the blacklist and we kept worrying that
somebody in the audience was gonna stand
up and go you know like someone's going
to think that they're watching their own
home movies and like shout out something
very
rely on the social contract that people
don't heckle at the theater you know
like it was but it was really
interesting like so what intermission
you'd be like so we had a real you don't
know crowd out there they were digging
it they were digging it they were old
enough to remember but they really
enjoyed it um yeah it was it was um it
was a blasted little like theater called
the Garry Marshall Theatre in Burbank
Toluca Lake if you want to get specific
um it's got a subscription base and it
was like what is that um 20 seats I
think but that's like intimate and also
feels like a full experience precisely
exactly that it was intimate but like
we're doing a play this is I got
wardrobe and these are sets and there's
an audience but it does feel like we're
in it all together
people had play bills you know it's
theater my career that was great I'm
super excited to play bill yeah that's
very cool okay now I want to get from
things that are very cool and sincere to
guilty pleasures is there anything that
you watch on TV that you listen to that
you consider a guilty pleasure even
though I don't like to call them guilty
pleasure anymore I like to call them
just like things that I like I like with
a sigh yeah you know I try not to put
garbage in my head you know I've got
friends who watch i watch all reality TV
I do put garbage of a lot of smart
people do and a lot of smart people are
able to watch it with a critical eye
yeah and not lose brain cells and isn't
that I maybe I just don't trust myself
to like not just watch this in tune out
or just get contemptuous or feel bad
about humanity yeah you can get upset
and it makes it's a waste of time to be
upset at it which is what I've learned
that just be kind of like it's
fascinating to me yeah if I could get
that anthropological distance I'd be all
I mean guilty pleasures I cry some 47
man I go what do you watch like what do
you when you have free time what I watch
I have to say about the stuff I watch is
is like the prestige critically
acclaimed [ __ ] what I listen to is all
over the goddamn map and there are times
where like for all of my punk and indie
rock credentials I need to hear scenes
from an Italian restaurant
about Brenda and Eddie and I need him to
take seven and a half minutes to tell me
about it
that's not cool and I'll own that but I
don't give a [ __ ] I saw him at the
Hollywood Bowl a couple years ago it was
a great show it just but you can you
wouldn't have this criticism on music
because you were in a band right I was
in a punk rock band oh yeah great house
parties and like squats I played a
[ __ ] squat in South Philly with stole
electricity there's a guy who has a
tattoo of my band on his ankle I've
slept on floors all up and down the east
coast I'm Punk as [ __ ] and you know what
since an Italian restaurant is a
gorgeous leap it's got three movements
grace it is a it is a piece it has a
[ __ ] auric as my ringtone
I've played squats squats I played a
building in Philadelphia where people
were not allowed to be living by the
city of Philadelphia and so you had
stolen electricity they would they they
were powering the amps by running cords
out to the street lamps where they had
bid jimmied open the bottom of the
street lamps I'm like okay okay South
Philly
the yeah I'm from across the bridge from
Philadelphia my parents still celebrate
actual address I can't help you no no I
work the Dave & Buster's on Penn's
Landing for a month it was the worst
experience of my life the most gorgeous
that's like a gritty specific that was
my like it was really bad but I got my
nose pierced on South Street great yeah
I got penis pasta credible tattoo on
South Street it's the worst street ever
and I was like that's our Mardi Gras
okay so give me this set up to your your
punk bands name was good sure oh you're
three kind of nerdy guys we were like
three guys who all had glasses and we
decided to lean into it so we all wore
like matching outfits like striped
shirts or whatever okay and we just were
not great so we decided to lean into
that and just be kind of loud and fast
and we're still poppy and what did you
play bass you play baby
and I sang half the songs okay so what
was the lead into playing this squat
that you mentioned we were on a little
tour of the East Coast and that was a
early days of the internet you know
we're like let's just er yeah I haven't
even been pre Napster a little girl yeah
we were using this incredibly
condescending no no no no I was still
using my a oh LCD so yeah fifteen three
hours no it was so it would have been it
would have been via my AOL account tours
and you would find like there would be
like message boards or people wanting
people to play yeah places like you
listen if you're going through this part
of the country this guy throws house
parties this guy is a promoter who does
small shows this guy is a bar who books
punk bands on Tuesday nights so this is
like pre Craigslist and everything like
that yeah but you would find it you know
you you couldn't the big promise that
you still had to text and we didn't have
a cellphone but I mean you could use you
could you could use the Internet insofar
as you could send somebody an email and
you okay we're gonna be coming through
town this day do you have any openings
you know anybody who has an opening and
that's how you would book at this level
you know and we do it ourselves it was
really know just it was mostly me which
is by the way if I'm like the logistic
voice of your band you're [ __ ] but we
made it work we got we got as far as
Athens Georgia and then back up which is
not nothing coming from New York that's
pretty impressive but we would play like
you would we'd do some clubs and we'd
get onto like some some punk bills at
clubs in like you know Knoxville okay
and ashy but then you'd play the really
fun ones were like somebody would rent a
hall in suburban Pennsylvania okay and
they rent a PA and the bands would come
in and whoever came the furthest would
get the largest chunk of the door really
and you know the further away we got
from home the more money we made and
we're talking like you know ninety bucks
on a good night nines about but millions
of dollars this is this up and we're off
to the next place and if we eat at
Waffle House we're fine you know
so yeah it was this incredible sort of
scrappy do-it-yourself experience that's
so fun it was really fun you know it was
a young man's game young man's game okay
I'm glad I had it but question for all
the inquiring minds that want to know is
eggheads music still available for
people to listen to on the internet
anywhere we did a reunion record between
the birth of my my two kids okay you can
find that on a streaming platform it's
called egghead would like a few words
with you that's amazing that's it and
not the one no it's it's just an album
it wasn't like a compilation it was
stuff we hadn't recorded first off the
early stuff is not available streaming
anywhere everyone small somebody posted
on YouTube uh-huh but the the the 2009
record is our til 2010 2009 since before
Walter was born okay is it's right there
and it has um it has my daughter can
[ __ ] up your daughter which is which was
our head your child yeah oh that's very
sentimental very and with a as a bonus
track the clean version my daughter can
mess up your daughter okay that's
incredible I'm gonna listen to that
we're gonna take a quick break and then
we're gonna get to the internet
questions that have oh gosh this really
informs me about a guest is when I seek
out questions from the internet and then
who would bother to like a question for
John Ross just that much free time just
the specifics that they want to know
about you really allows me to know who
you are as a person to keep it fresh I
just skimmed I didn't look very good I
didn't look very responses okay well
we'll be right back and you'll give some
specific answers
[Music]
too deep this episode of nacho deep is
brought to you by cafe monster for many
of us Jack you know this all too well
the day doesn't start until we get that
morning energy boost I'm talking about
coffee oh you're talking about coffee
and now there's a new way to enjoy your
daily cup of joe thanks to cafe monster
it's available in vanilla mocha and
salted caramel cafe monster is shaking
up there ready to drink coffee category
with indulgent gourmet coffee that's
only 190 calories not to mention with a
hundred fifty milligrams of caffeine
from coffee beans B vitamins and coffee
fruit extract cafe monster offers a
simplified energy blend that contains a
third less sugar than the leading
national brand in fact it's one hundred
fewer calories per bottle then the
competition but you would never know it
by tasting it instead you get the same
feel and flavor as your local coffee
house without having to wait in line
that's my favorite part the lack of
human interaction happens caffeine into
my body not to mention the flavors are
oh so delicious yeah yeah well the mocha
you told me to try the multi mocha is
literally like chocolate milk it is like
chocolate milk and it's dangerously
delicious yeah guys try it trust me it's
really good cafe monster chill it down
shake it up enjoy support for today's
show comes from
Rafi's roth these shoes are stylish
sustainable and comfortable enough for
everyday wear anywhere I were flats all
the time I'm a tall lady and these are
some of the most comfortable stylish
little flats I got once I have like a
little cute giraffe print going on
because I'm very into animal prints on
my feet and I can attest that they are
so comfortable so stylish and also
sustainable with three fashionable
styles the flat the point and the loafer
for women and girls and an amazing color
and pattern selection that's always
getting updated not to mention they're
the softest shoe that you will put on
your feet seriously you won't believe
that they're made from recycled plastic
water bottles I'm dead serious and a
major added bonus they're machine
washable because let's face it our feet
sweat we get gross I can attest to this
I'm a human walking garbage pile of
trash and these shoes make me feel
beautiful I
love my Rafi's and I know you will too
right now Rafi's has an amazing deal for
you beautiful listeners use code grace
to get free shipping no minimum that's
free shipping and free returns and
exchanges on your rocky shoe when you go
to Rafi's our o th why s calm and enter
code grace this is a no-brainer shoes
that are comfortable stylish and
sustainable plus free shipping get
yourself a pair today Rafi's comm promo
code grace get this deal won't less okay
I'm gonna ask you the two questions
asked every single guest that's on the
podcast and the first is who alive or
dead would you most want to throw cold
spaghetti at most want to throw cold
spaghetti and golly you know hmm
it's hard to say but I'm gonna go with
young young pre-pre dementia Reagan oh
okay I'm probably gonna Molly still
Governor of California and get him out
of politics well he remembers it yeah
well he remembers it and because I also
don't want to throw you know throw
spaghetti at someone who's going through
that that's rough but it sounds like was
it like a bifurcation point where like I
could I could just be an amiable old
character actor like Fred MacMurray or I
could just start [ __ ] up the world
because there's so much that's wrong
right now that you can trace back to the
policies of Reagan in the early 80s and
and I think his his political offspring
I don't know how political you get on
the show and I what's called not too
deep but I feel like his political
offspring are still doing damage and
yeah yeah so that I go with young Reagan
I thought you're gonna say young Sheldon
[Laughter]
single-camera and then he went multi-car
Maroney when he got into his thirties I
know how that happened
the other question I ask every guest to
tell us tell us your worst pants
[ __ ] story or close call but you can
only use three words or small phrases or
an inner mix of the two mine for example
is college jogging front lawn ones that
one's a - it you can do whatever you
want you know I'm saying one word it's a
- ed I'm warning you in advance got it
Pan Am building temping Wow okay so that
was your quickest okay commando did the
rest of the day wearing khakis by the
way so there but for the grace of God
keep it a secret if they notice they
didn't say anything tell me that they've
had to throw out their underwear in the
middle of New York City somewhere that's
the statistic I want in New York is how
many times a day someone is having to
cut themselves out of their own
underwear and throw in the garbage and
just deal well cuz you don't you know
you have nothing you also pack for the
day right but you leave your house in
the more and you pack for the day I
don't but you just you're never gonna
get home again right once you leave in
the morning unless you're super
unemployed you're just not gonna go back
no that's I still carry bags and they
still put extra clothes and extra things
in my car as if like what is the worst
possible thing that could have happened
to me today and leave me completely like
on an island of one and you have that
lack you have that luxury in LA and you
don't in New York but yeah I asked my
Pete on the way to the it's now the Met
Life Building on top of Grand Central
Station yeah yes I used to be the Pan Am
building myself in a story rather
handsome as well and I wish I remember
what the industry that I was temping in
was I don't oddly enough which is not
not like me but I remember it was a very
like I went and it was a very like a lot
of oak in the opposite beautiful really
I was like um yeah I'm all set where's
the restaurant yeah this is my work
station great I mean right back I'm
going to leave my mark thank you for
having me
okay now we're gonna get into these
Twitter questions
someone to know what's the best way to
awkwardly end a conversation [ __ ] your
pants on the way to reach out I think
that is actually pretty perfect and also
like the person can't tell you know you
get out of conversation they have a
story everybody wins
[Laughter]
someone oh how great does it feel being
on Grace's podcast well that's a joke
about that
I know a speech impediment yeah okay how
is that for you I'm off I'm off the
clock guy listen all right I don't do
this I don't do the speech impediment
for my do people have you ever had
anyone come up I mean I'm sure maybe you
have have people come up and be like do
the voice oh god yes really god I've
been asked to like leave I've been asked
to I did once for charity I actually
watched outgoing message for somebody on
their voicemail that's very kind yes
with the speech impediment yeah people
who asked me to do it and I mean I'm not
a dick I will I will do it fine okay and
I also like to ask what's your most
awkward encounter with someone that's a
fan or knows the show or know something
you've been in or is obsessed with the
band etc all right now I'm gonna spare
you the SuperDuper details okay I just
miss you know the show is called not too
deep but I gotta go a little deep for
him please I lost my mom this past
summer
okay thank you and it was a total shock
we did not see it coming she was fine
and then she was not she was gone okay
was she totally like French accident you
know Wow and Irish goodbye yeah and I
went back to New York and I was
I met my my cousin came in from from
Jersey actually he was and she works in
Newark and she's like the closest thing
I have to a sibling out there and I
think if you should come in I need some
help with some Leo logistical stuff she
comes off the train at at Penn Station
she said what's up I'm like well you
know it's a whole thing
like I gotta talk to the medical
examiner's office and it's gonna take
there's some stuff it's gonna take a
couple days to handle the the
identifying of the Bonnie and then I got
a once we get once that's identified
then we can get a death certificate
but we're not out of the woods we can
take the death certificate out of the
surrogate court surrogate court has to
do has to vet me to make sure that I can
have access to my mom's apartment which
is of had locked by the police right now
so they have to make sure that I'm the
only living heir or whatever I'm going
into like gnarly details of what's going
on Kripke yeah I haven't told that story
publicly and I I looked at my cousin I
was like should I tell a lot is going on
we're at the padlock part of the
conversation yeah you know because it
could be anybody right so they gotta
they gotta yeah probably dental records
since you've asked in a way like pops a
very intense balloon it popped a very
intense balloon we had an amazing laugh
out of it it's not often that like you
know no one in my family is in the
entertainment industry so really no one
no one and so it it's gotta be it's like
the rare moment we're like oh I guess
John does have his challenge like a
brand new side a brand new side of my
world yeah like I don't think she and
she's very empathetic but you can never
expect you can never explain that to
someone like that and again I'm I walk
around the streets you know unbothered
most days I have given up a certain
amount of privacy and and never was it
more apparent I mean almost feels I
don't know your mom but it almost feels
like your mom sending this like she was
hilarious oh my god she was exactly the
perfect moment for that to happen yeah I
found it funny no question that's one of
the reason the mill to tell you no but
that's also yeah and incredibly stab a
beautiful moment that you're like the
universe works in weird way it really
does yes
you'll take your laughs where you can
get them John and also the speech
impediment will never ever leave okay
it's almost no the most memorable moment
from filming speechless I
because you guys are still filming right
yeah we're started season three yes
season 3 will have started by the time
this podcast is that okay there's a
little backlog of five weeks on Hulu I
believe it's also you can watch it on
YouTube episodes on YouTube Kenny yeah
did that this morning there's been a lot
um you know we cuz you guys shoot in LA
we shoot in LA but we shot our season
premiere in London really yeah we went
to London for a season premiere the
story being that we have to go ask mini
my dad for money and mini strivers dad
was John Cleese which was crazy but I
mean we we shut down Trafalgar Square
right in front of the National Portrait
Gallery no National Gallery in DC and we
had this like massive location permit to
shoot right in the middle of London and
I felt like James Bond yeah yes and the
crew was like only never shoot around
yeah now we always we're off from and
away Wimbledon year but never shoot in
central London like this and it really
was like what the where the Bourne
movies shoot like right in front of the
fountains and everything and you know
looky-loos and everything and it looks
amazing I just saw some footage it looks
incredible if you're like yeah you got
the most out of London but that was
pretty awesome
crazy experience like oh we're just
shutting down this giant like portion of
London it's like shoot it's like
shutting down a chunk of Times Square or
Hollywood and Highland I mean it really
is a massively foot trafficked area that
we you know three hours I think I would
be incredibly riddled with anxiety like
having to perform within the time
restraints or constraints of like this
whole like everything being held up for
this yeah it's I made sure that I was a
like a hundred and ten percent off book
I mean I'm always pretty diligent about
that but I was like really like we gotta
be on we don't get this right we're at a
position where we don't get this wrong
because every take has to be usable
because who knows yeah so it was but
yeah there's just like tons of like
sightseers and then people recognize me
from BIGBANG which is actually pretty
big over in the UK oh yeah cool yeah it
is cool but there was also just a lot of
like you know young people taking this
tax
right behind the people who were paid to
take my photo but yeah it was great yeah
super cool okay someone to know what's
the most inappropriate question you've
been asked in interviews I would say I
would like a kind of expand this to like
what's the question that you're just
sick of answering because I'm sure Big
Bang and your whole history and
entertainment I will continue to answer
it politely sure but what's the one that
you a question about the speech
impediment whose idea it was
Oh whose idea well yeah cuz it was
whether it was yours or a writers via
whether I brought it to the audition or
whether it was on a strip and the answer
is neither it was sprung on me on the
audition oh interesting shot Gloria
thought it might be interesting to give
the guy a certain amount of
vulnerability and he asked for no he
asked no they asked his name far more
subtle they asked for like sort of that
Tom Brokaw liquid L thing I'm like yeah
sure absolutely you're nodding you know
what I mean right that's subtle and
understated and instead I did this Elmer
Fudd thing we are literally 10 years
later talking about well I won't ask you
anything else about it
fine I will I will it's I would prefer
not to but I will absolutely graciously
continue absolutely cuz you're a kind
person what's the best heckle you've
ever heard someone to know I'm sure you
block this I mean have you guys ever had
in Big Bang like someone in the audience
ever like have to be commenting it's
shot by the Warner Brothers cops no no
God no that is a controlled environment
yes and also the people who get their
because it's hard to get a show yeah no
I've never had I've never had heckling
at a edit I probably I really I haven't
we haven't done enough I did a ton of
improv but it's just for whatever reason
impromptu and get a lot of hecklers or
mocked one time doing stand-up I haven't
done a ton of stand okay have you ever
done stand-up I've done it maybe 12
times 13 times maybe that's it I've
never damn terrified of it well I did it
because I was terrified I was like you
know there's your fear follow your fear
there's people out there who like go
into combat I can handle standing
I'm telling jokes you know fair
assessment yes it was part of you trying
to like kind of you know our version
therapy it sure you know what it's funny
I don't remember being heckled but I
remember kind of bombing at you know
even past the haha cafe I'm Lankershim
yes okay so it's it's called the haha
cafe for one thing which hilarious
should let you know it's a place for
people that are funny so I'm up there
and my wife and I were like daring each
other right after we moved here to do to
do stand-up and we were really it would
go out and we would like put together
five minutes and we had enough friends
that we could get thrown on to like some
sort of Tuesday night so you'd both go
do it okay and I remember humming but
getting polite laughter from the man
sitting down in front who is David
Faustino from married with children
that's what happens when you bomb in LA
you don't you bomb in front of someone
you recognize and I remember just being
like not noticing until I was up on
stage like hey hey hi I'm John I did
that guy that's David Faustino from
America and he gave me he's he ieaves
laughing very politely he's right up in
front like he's so close to like the
stage light is hitting him too you know
yeah and David if you're listening to
this and I'm sure he's a huge fan you
were very gracious and you probably
don't remember it or maybe you do but I
do and it were you were very gracious
and thank you for being kind to me I
don't do stand if you're wondering no I
don't do stand-up very often anymore
thank you story I mean it wasn't even a
heckle story it was just like this it
was just bombing in front of somebody I
really pretty I mean and also that he
was sitting front row I mean he came
there to find new talent
well you're manifesting maybe you guys
will work together in the future here's
hoping I do in a heartbeat oh really oh
hell yeah okay well we've reached the
end of the podcast this has been super
super fun great yeah and thank you so
much for your time thank you for your
stories every guest that makes time for
being on the podcast we tried to create
a special personalized fortune cookie
for
so we wanted to give you the
gift for giving us the gift of your time
it's a personalized fortune cookie just
for you I open it here I take it yeah
this is fresh this is a fresh fortune
yep it still means fresh then yes
wrapped they're fresh the office you
used to work at thought you were just
taking a long vacation to find yourself
and are so expecting you back to the
temperate year-old is confusing very
tired
I bet 20 plus years for 20 years without
health benefit god bless that janitor
that had to take out that garbage full
of shitty underwear John thank you again
so much for being here
rich my pleasure where can people find
you online where can they see anything
that you're working on what's coming uh
let me just um October 5th Friday
October 5th at 8:30 TGIF TGIF thank God
it's funny yeah and I will be promoting
the hell out of it on my various social
media platforms where I am at johnross
Maui at Twitter Instagram and I can't
only tumblr I mean I feel like in it
that's the brand now but please for all
of you that go out there and listen to
egghead yeah music please tweet at me
where I can listen to it directly
because I I got it I got it get informed
get in there and I got a I'm now the
grassroots promoter for the second
reunion
[Laughter]
goodbye 2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep cafe
Monster is shaking up they're ready to
drink coffee category with indulgent
gourmet coffee that's only 190 calories
available in vanilla mocha and salted
caramel with 150 milligrams of caffeine
from coffee beans B vitamins and coffee
fruit extract in every bottle Cafe
Monster offers a simplified energy blend
that contains 1/3 less sugar than the
leading national brand but you
look at all the feel and flavor of your
local coffee house you just don't have
to wait in line and I got to tell you
guys these flavors are delicious
try the mocha trust me it tastes like
chocolate milk delicious cafe monster
drink it down shake it up
enjoy not too deep as a production of
grace helbig incorporated a producer and
directed by Jack ferry producer and
editor melissa demons writing by Diane
King production assistants by Audriana
Monte agudo post-production sound by
Chris Henry and an extra special thanks
to Flula for the theme music
[Music]